[Musique]
la voix de claire diterzi résonne de
nouveaux atours pour avoir plus de
liberté elle vient de monter sa propre
structure
ce que j'aime avec cette idée de
compagnie c'est l'idée d'aller à la
rencontre des publics et de ne pas avoir
comme le système l'imposent pour les
chanteurs une façon de penser comme très
capitaliste il a montré c'est à dire des
carrières qui sont jalonnées par cet
objet discographie moi j'ai pensé plus
tôt différemment déjà scène objet
scénique est l'idée qui en ai plein
d'allant dans la même année donc c'est à
dire je suis tout le temps création
toujours à envoyer des deux petits
satellites comme ça pour développer mon
message pour aller à la rencontre des
publics
ça peut donner sa 1/2 intimiste avec
stéphane un percussionniste ingénieux
cymbales
mais le duc a ou encore coquillages une
sorte de cabinet de curiosités musicales
oui oui tout tout peut servir ouais
j'espère bien sinon se ferait chier
quand même pas comment mr dray ça c'est
pas grave on s'ennuierait issus du punk
claire a fait un joli parcours elle
regrette juste la normalisation dans le
métier d'artiste et c'est à ça serra a
forcé le regard a changé il sert à
la merde
aujourd'hui les gens public production
n'a plus en plus envie d'être rassurés
pour des raisons économiques mais non
moi je continue ma route c'est à dire
dont je pense qu'une chercheuse
prochain rendez vous avec la chanteuse
je garde le chien et le rck est cette
fois avec un orchestre symphonique
[Musique]